I made this video back in the day when I
was working on tasty Junior videos and
this is by far one of my favorite
recipes that I've ever made
there is nothing I hate more than
standing over a hot stove on a summer
day flipping darn pancakes it's Sunday
morning I'm tired the last thing I want
to do is just be sweating and flipping
no it's no different from making regular
pancakes you can use your own favorite
recipe if you want but probably double
it and you're just gonna pour the batter
over a piece of parchment paper in a
sheet pan as an aunt I was trying to
figure out ways to make cooking a fun
experience for me and also an experience
that saves me time and effort while
getting nearly the same result with what
I was going through in my personal life
I was able to transition that into my
work you can customize your pancakes no
matter what your preference is and
really go anywhere with these you can
jazz them up and put peaches or
blueberries strawberries bananas
chocolate whatever tickles your fancy
and you stick it in the oven for 15
minutes at 425 degrees Fahrenheit and
they come out perfectly cooked
and browned and golden and cut them into
different shapes you can get more
artistic it's delicious it's easy it
saves me so much time and it's something
that I'm gonna continue to use for the
rest of my life
[Music]
another free time-saving tip for you if
by any chance you do end up having
leftovers which doesn't happen in my
house very often once they're cooled you
can put them into a resealable bag and
freeze them for up to a month and heat
them up and serve them again for
breakfast why not talk about a time
saver
you could even throw another pan into
the oven that has your bacon on it and
you're good to go
you got breakfast in one oven these
pancakes are a hit in my household to
this day and I will never make pancakes
on a griddle again ever
my favorite combination has got to be
the banana and chocolate chip one and I
sometimes add like little bacon
sprinkles in there put the maple syrup
and butter hold on hold please I need to
go eat this I'm hungry
[Music]
you